bienvenue dans ce journal c'est l'image
du jour on craignait de découvrir des
rescapés malades ou diminuer bien ce
sont des hommes en pleine santé
débordant de vie qui sont remontés à la
surface au chili
une prouesse technique une grande scène
de communion nationale aussi voici ces
images elles sont commentés par dorothée
olliéric personne ne voulait remonter en
premier pour ne pas voler la vedette aux
autres nouvelles manches et florencio
avalos 31 ans qui a été désigné sophis
byron ne peut retenir ses larmes s'est
levé par les applaudissements des
sauveteurs
le mineur sort calmement des gestes de
tendresse après une épreuve de 69 22
mètres sous terre le monde entier voit
en direct le deuxième mineur pénétrer
dans l'étroite capsule phénix la
remontée dure 15 minutes
chaque article mario on t'attend marion
il reste plus beaucoup merci les habits
merci les pousses du mineur est
agréablement surprise en entendant les
cris de joie de son mât est arrivé
mario sepulveda débordant d'énergie sort
des pierres rapporte et du fond de la
lune cadeau souvenir pour les sauveteurs
et pour le président chinois se
précipitent ensuite vers ses amis
mineurs
dopé par la liberté retrouvée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extravagant et extravertie celui qu'on
appelle déjà super mario est un mineur
qui pense à son travail avec humilité
ton ami dans cette épreuve notre folie
nos coeurs de mineurs et toute notre
expérience professionnelle demain il
faudra de vrais changements pour ceux
qui travaillent dans les mines des
améliorations on ne peut pas rester
comme ça les heures passent
la mine se vident les sauvetages se
suivent mais ne se ressemblent pas à
travers ce puits de secours filmé depuis
la nacelle et après les plus agiles ce
sont les plus faibles qui retrouve là
parmi les 33 mineurs un bolivien que le
président evo morales est venu féliciter
en personne le chef d'état bolivien a
également remercié son homologue chilien
pour sebastian pinera s'est aussi
l'unité du pays qui est célébré
aujourd'hui on à l'hôtel qu'elle a dit
on avec une nuit où la vie a été plus
que la mort où l'espérance a triomphé de
l' angoisse ou la note qu'elle entame
qui nous fait sentir davantage comme des
êtres humains des frères manon unis dans
la force la volonté le courage est prêt
à affronter ce que nous réserve le futur
à les balades
c'est d'ailleurs tout un pays qui a
passé une nuit blanche et les chiliens
n'ont pas fini de fêter le sauvetage des
les mineurs de fond devenu et route